oh hey boss your movie but Destroyer for
the Awakening is on track to lose 400
million dollars oh no we need your CGI
people to fix it up make it more fun oh
but but the release date is tomorrow
right so I have one idea through the
process of Science and developments in
AI in English please we are able to
resurrect the recently deceased and star
of the butt Destroyer franchise William
a butt for a cameo that will melt the
hearts of audiences everywhere is that
ethical I'm sure it's what he'd want
well according to the New York Times the
last words he ever spoke were and I
quote I'm so happy to be done with the
butt Destroyer franchise it ruined my
life wow those corporate losers ever use
CGI to put me in another butt Destroyer
film I will be rolling in my grave for
all of eternity his family signed off on
don't listen to my family just take a
look at what a four star effects team to
whip up in the course of 24 hours the
results I think are impressive from one
but Destroyer to another you are the
future of this franchise I love you wow
I know that looks terrible marketing
says it will help us sell 12 more
tickets oh let's do it then